[Musique]
il
bon
[Musique]
ils attendent des peter toutes les
filles qui ont disparu on n'était jamais
retrouvé
là que je peux me recueillir sermon
deuil avec d'autres familles
pour moi n'est pas arrivé au bout de la
chaîne on apporte trouvé qu'il est qu on
a retrouvé certains corps de sarah mason
n'a pas été retrouvé byd auto psy qu'on
peut être
et j'en ai fait une dépression j'ai été
hospitalisé hier
on se mélange et du léon on voit tu vois
des personnes entre 1975 et 1990
une vingtaine de jeunes femmes
disparaissent dans la région d'auxerre
à cette époque plusieurs criminels
devenus célèbres comme emile louis
michel fourniret y séjournent en toute
impunité
personne ne fait la moindre relation
entre cette disparition et l'activité
criminelle de ces prédateurs ni la
police ni la justice ne sont capables
pendant toutes ces années de résoudre
ne serait ce qu'un seul de ces cas
quarante ans plus tard il est temps de
revenir sur ce que tout le monde appelle
à auxerre la sphère des disparues de
l'yonne
[Musique]
un homme sans qui sans doute rien
n'aurait changé
pierre monnoir va dès le début se battre
pour découvrir la vérité
il fonde avec les familles des disparus
une association qui va lutter sans cesse
pour obtenir des réponses que ni la
police ni la justice ne semble vouloir
leur apporter même pour ça il a fallu
batailler pour avoir une statue dans un
endroit accessible ce qu'on voulait nous
la mettre la mairie d'auxerre voulait la
mettre dans un cimetière donc voilà et
je voulais que pour les failles et les
familles souhaitaient que pour les corps
qui n'ont pas été retrouvés mais les un
endroit pour se recueillir et la preuve
c'est qu'on voit pour entendre des
fleurs
[Musique]
m
des fleurs pour françoise lemoine 27 ans
aperçue pour la dernière fois en 1975 à
auxerre des fleurs pour christine
marleau 16 ans qui s'évaporent dans la
nature le 23 janvier 77 le 4 avril
c'est jacqueline weiss 19 ans qui doit
se rendre en train à wallon et que l'on
ne retrouve jamais chantal grade 18 ans
puis madeleine de juste disparaissent en
bernadette lemoine la soeur de françoise
disparaît elle en 78 nul ne reverra non
plus martine renaud 16 ans aperçue pour
la dernière fois le 26 septembre 1979
c'est cette jeune disparue dont deux
sont mineurs sont tous des pupilles de
la dass
[Musique]
dès les années 80 un gendarme christian
jambert suspecte un chauffeur de car de
la région nommée emile louis j'ai fait
une enquête
disons non officiels parce que c'était
défi de la dass et elle n'était déclarée
disparue par personne parce que la
plupart était majeure je me suis entêté
et je me suis rendu compte qu'en fait
c'étaient des disparitions suspectes
parce que ses fils à jo jamais rien pas
vu malgré le rapport qui incrimine
clairement emile louis que christian
jambert remet à la justice
celui ci n'est pas inquiété une
vingtaine d'années passent les familles
se désespère emile louis lui des ménages
dans le sud de la france
c'est une émission de télévision qui va
faire rebondir l'enquète en 1996 nous
avons retrouvé
c'est en désespoir de cause que question
jambert s'adresse à la télévision grâce
à cette interview
il espère avoir enfin les moyens de
faire bouger les choses
elle a disparu elle est partie d'un
foyer un mercredi après-midi à 10 ans
était petite copine qu'elle partait avec
ce chauffeur de car sans le désigner
qu'elles partent avec lui parce que ce
chauffeur de cas comme à l'été de la
glace avait retrouvé sa maman et ils
l'emmenaient qui lui avait dit lendemain
le mercredi après midi
il emmenait pour aller voir sa maman
qu'il avait retrouvé et elle n'est
jamais réapparue
et canton de seurre lemoine c'est
exactement pareil on aimerait partir de
chez leurs parents avec ce même individu
toujours le même chacune leur tour
permettant l espace de quelques mois
elles perdent elles disparaissent on les
revoit jamais
jean-pierre et cathy marleau étaient
présents en 1996 à cette émission
c'est là qu'il découvre que christine la
soeur de jean pierre fait sans doute
partie des victimes du tueur en série
il n'avait jamais été prévenu par
quiconque de la disparition de christine
qu'est ce qu'on s'est mariée on avait
demandé des nouvelles de christine et on
nous a dit allez majeur elle fait sa vie
elle a quitté le sont jamais en galilée
disparaît plus l'âge de 16 ans par la
télévision c'est pas la télévision qu'on
l'a appris à la suite de l'émission les
marleau comme toutes les familles de
victimes
vous rencontrez le gendarme jambert mais
qu'est ce qui vous a dit georges honneur
et bien qu'ils avaient vraiment
travaillé dur sur les dossiers et qui se
rappelait bien de tout ce qu'il avait
notifié dans le dossier qu'il avait
qu'il avait fait alors après c'est vrai
qu'il a été un petit peu plus pour
réserver pour nous donner des détails
parce que je pense qu'il voulait d'abord
les données la justice choses qui ne
pouvaient faire le dossier d' enquête
préliminaire que j'avais fait bon je
l'avais déposée au parquet comme tout
genre doit le faire enquête officielle
qui soit fait et à ma grande surprise
j'ai jamais plus entendu parler de ce
dossier
le passage de christian jambert à la
télévision change la donne
la section de recherches de la
gendarmerie de paris s'intéressent à
emile louis à cette époque il habite à
draguignan dans le var
il refuse de parler aux journalistes d
finalement suite à l'insistance de son
voisin qui le pousse à se défendre
emile louis fini par accepter de nous
parler
[Musique]
tout défi que qui ont disparu vous les
avez connus mais bien sûr je les ai
connus blier et transporter d'un mot car
plusieurs de ses filles donc que vous
avez ramené que vous avez ramené ont
disparu par l'ase par la suite où
pendant comment ça c'est que les gens se
sont inquiétés sur la sur nbc vous en
parliez pas entre vous engagement donc
là on entre le chauffeur leur parler
pour ça il faut faire le monde avait sa
ligne je l'avais la personne ne
s'inquiétait personnes et pourquoi on ne
sait pas quelles raisons vous les
connaissiez bien il y en a plein qui
vous qui vous aimez beaucoup ont plané
un seul mais personne n'en parlait - les
personnes à la créa en parlait jamais et
pourtant les filles disparaissait et un
personnel en parlait et pour quelle
raison partageant service mais ça
faisait bizarre de voir des filles enfin
depuis de pouvoir depuis voir ses fils a
pour une raison qui guérit
[Musique]
ces soi-disant fugueuse ont séjourné
presque tout au centre de mon merci
pierre monnoir tient à nous emmener
découvrir ce foyer aujourd'hui
désaffectée
[Musique]
mon merci c'est là que total qui peut
démarrer et c'est l'axé beaucoup de ces
jeunes filles sont passées et minoui
aussi rendait des services dans cet
établissement
c'était l'arbre est maintenant bien
évidemment mais c'était beaucoup mieux
avant puisqu'il n'y avait pas de
chauffage et enfin chose et c'est
vraiment triste
à chaque fois que je passe dans ce coin
je fais un tout petit pèlerinage d'arrêt
bah oui effectivement c'est c'est la
misère c'est ce et les viols qui ont été
commis l'un des jeunes fans de la dass
on voit bien les personnes sans
l'inquiéter même pas la gendarmerie même
pas la date les victimes deux mots merci
ne se limite pas au seul disparu
le foyer était à l'époque dirigée par un
certain pierre charlier bien connue des
1000 louis je sais que les gamines et
lille est toujours premier choix la
douche était un jour en semaine le dow
rappelle péter le jour eagle perche à
riesa promet de les regarder dans les
douches vous trouviez ça bizarre quand
même
oui là là là oui parce que c'est une
chose je ne serai jamais père lire
quels rapports vous aviez que monsieur
charia aux abords de boulot c'est tout
vous avez jamais été invité chez lui
enfermé jamais j'ai même pensé fait que
commencer
pierre charrier sera condamné en 1992 à
six ans de prison pour attentat à la
pudeur avec violence
[Musique]
parmi les malheureuses pensionnaires du
foyer de mon merci une jeune femme a
miraculeusement échappé à cette
hécatombe
elle avait 16 ans au moment des faits je
suis mme bélanger n'a jamais pu oublier
le calvaire qu'elle a vécu à mon merci
savez-vous qu ont été troqués
terriblement là bas je crois que ça a
commencé là-bas l'histoire de lexomil
parce que j'en prend constamment et le
jour que je n'ai pas cessé
vous le verrez certainement pas mettre
mon corps et tremble pas ce que parce
que mais c'est une drogue puis comment
voulez vous qu'on sait des habitués et
quant à commença à 4 ha c'est dans cette
atmosphère pour le moins tendu de mon
merci qu'elle rencontre emile louis qui
effectue quelques fois des tâches de
jardiniers en plus de celle de
chauffeurs l'appeler le jardinier si
vous voulez nous en avions un peu peur
avec certaines étaient très jovial avec
certains il était très vents des comptes
il y avait déjà des livres 2 2 quand je
pourrai vous dire ça faisait rire moi
dérive un peu olé olé de femme nue qui
donnait ça tiens tu vas bouquin ceci
cela dans la ville dans le dortoir et
puis je voulais dire watabe au début il
m'appréciait pas si je voulais dire
quelque chose il disait fait que je me
taise
on n'avait pas adressé la parole est ce
qu'on m'a demandé quelque chose
alors bon il était très impressionnant
parce qu'ils la voile
elle a résonné à manger toujours ce
vieux mas vieux qui n'avait pas 30 ans
mais quand on a 15 ans vous savez tout
le monde et moi tout le monde était
vieux ce possible que ce vieux là mais
j'avais présenté petit à petit il
devenait aussi plus jovial et
sympathique et is acquitté si je
mangeais pas de trop et puis aussi on
parlait un peu de tout d'une chose d'une
autre et moi je suis très malgré mon
manque de savoir étant jeune j'avais
quand même appris à lire et la lecture
m'intéresse même de ce jour nous deux ce
sujet je lisais ça comme ça en douce
malgré l'interdiction est malgré tout
attaque j'ai dit mais moi alors nous
deux j'aime bien ça et tout l autre il
m'a dit mais bon alors mais il fallait
le dire plutôt parce que moi j'en ai
mais c'est incroyable bête alors après
manger j'ai tant donné il fallait le tir
une chose une autre on discute et puis
tout le monde s'en bat les unes derrière
les autres
quand il m'a rappelé alors même d'imiter
leave me dit viens on va les chercher et
je suis il n'y a pas eu de violence à ce
moment là on me dit moi je suis dit tu
lien va te donner des livres j'ai c'est
chouette chouette je vais arras je vais
pouvoir lire ça comme je peux et puis
et puis voilà et quand j'ai été dans la
cabane si vous voulez j'ai été d'une
menace est très fort ça cesse
j'atterris comme ça très fort et hop les
mains dans le dos mais la tâche très
vite et puis alors vous avez beau faire
ça vous ne pourrez pas boudé faire il y
avait des outils là pas mal d'outils
l'unpf aussi je sais très bien ce que
c'est vous savez ça fait ça avec un nom
je sais plus j'ai pas été blessé vous
voyez mal an il y avait des trucs je
voyais j'avais beau faire ça j'avais
beau hurler mais j'aimerais tout ce que
je pouvais à pleins poumons
amy lui se contente de la violer et la
laissent s'échapper si josty n'a pu s'en
sortir
ça ne sera malheureusement pas le cas
des autres jeunes filles disparues
à paris le cabinet seban représente
l'ensemble des victimes d'emile louis
corinne herrmann y est avocate elle est
la meilleure spécialiste de la sphère
des disparues de l'yonne
émile oui on ne connaît pas exactement
la façon dont il a tué les victimes
parce qu'il ne l'a jamais vraiment dit
même dans ses aveux il a été assez loin
des actes de mises à mort mais sa façon
d'approcher les victimes sa façon de les
prendre dans sa toile de les entourer
comme dans un cocon pour qu'on ne les
aperçoivent pas et qu'on aperçoive pas
lui c'est de cette façon d'approcher ses
victimes
elle sera identique pendant 50 ans donc
ça on le retrouve et grâce aux victimes
vivantes on va comprendre comment il
joue avec elle comme un i s'approcher
d'elle comment il est ficelé comment ils
les apprivoiser comment ils les anémies
voulait jocelyne bélanger terrorisés se
taira longtemps comment voulez vous que
ça puisse en parler ce n'était dans la
possibilité d'en parler et même si
j'avais parlé je me sens coupable mans
avec ces histoires là
[Musique]
toutes ces filles là qu'est ce qu'elles
sont devenues
mystère et boule de meubles moi j'ai
toujours dit que j'étais pour rien dans
cette affaire d'agression au clocher qui
va on y va à mort comblés toujours su
doser le collimateur d'un vous les avez
tout connu emile louis prétend ne rien
savoir sur ces disparitions
et pourtant les gendarmes de la section
de recherches de paris ont terminé leur
enquête et ils ne sont pas du tout de
cet avis
[Musique]
depuis la fin des années 80 emile louis
vit dans le var d'abord résidents d'un
camping il commet des attouchements sur
des enfants pour lesquels il est
condamné en 1992 il épouse chantal
paradis et emménage à draguignan
les habitants de la résidence des billes
est loin de se douter de ce qui se passe
le prennent pour un bébé bien tranquille
a dû couper les cheveux était coiffeuse
[Musique]
jamais il te disais bonjour il est
avenant
comment je vis je suis bien je suis rue
réclame mais j'en ai marre qu'on vient
de faire cher je joue avec ça compte
toujours merveille ces histoires là que
je suis là béthouart tu prennes mais
doivent croire je crois un criminel je
bois nasa 512 go jusqu'à violeur délire
pourtant en décembre 2000 quelques jours
après cette interview
la section de recherches de paris ayant
réuni suffisamment d'éléments le
gendarme éric baron décide de le mettre
en garde à vue
interpellons donc 12 décembre à 18h15
on l'a ramené à l'unité après la
perquisition qui était négative une fois
à l'unité nous avons commencé un petit
peu a discuté avec lui puisqu'il posez
toujours les mêmes questions pourquoi on
était là pourquoi vingt ans après on
revenus l'emmerdé en gros tu lisais avec
ses sons en ces termes avec cette
histoire et il voulait surtout savoir ce
qu'on avait dans le dossier au bout de
quelques heures on va dire deux heures
il a commencé à nous parler un petit peu
de la prescription
au bout d'un une prescription et visera
donc on a vu en vous embête avec sa main
vous me convient à merveille
donc il a voulu voir le code on vient
montrer des codes ce qui est l arctique
de la prescription et on l'a laissé
au temps de repos jusqu'à 23 heures
[Musique]
s'il veut que la prescription soit mise
en place
il valait qu'il désavoue les faits donc
c'est ce qui va l'amener à parler en
disant finalement moi je suis plus grand
tueur en série le plus grand tueur du
monde parce que vous pouvez pas me
poursuivre les faits sont prescrits il
dit pas je suis innocent il faut quand
même se rappeler qu'ils me louis ne dit
pas je suis innocent il ne le dira
jamais une fois qu'il a été persuadé la
prescription
il a commencé à parler jusqu'à 4 heures
du matin il nous a parlé de cette jeune
fille
comment il avait eu contact avec elles
comment il les avait rencontrés
l'endroit où les avait amenés donc le
nom du serein puisqu'il nous a dit les
avoir tous tant mieux le long du rhin ce
qui s'est passé le long du rhin comment
il les a tuées quelles étaient ses liens
qu'il avait avec chacune de ces jeunes
filles où il les avait rencontrés et en
fin d'audition enfin tôt le matin il
nous a dit pour vous prouver ma bonne
foi je suis prêt à vous conduire à
l'endroit où gens très jeunes filles
nous l'avons conduit à rouvrir
et à ce moment là on lui a demandé de
nous indiquer les sept lieux où il avait
déposé les sept jeunes filles
donc il nous a indiqué tous les lieux où
il avait déposé qui ont été numérotées
de 1 à 7 par nos techniciens la plus
grande des victoires ça a été quand on a
trouvé le premier corps qui étaient au
trou numéro un
on a trouvé fin décembre et il a de
deuxième corps a été trouvé en début
d'année vers le mois de janvier
[Musique]
les deux corps retrouvés sont ceux de
madeleine de justes et de jacqueline
veille ce nom christian jambert avait
clairement évoqué les cas une hauteur
des filles en question qui avait disparu
il y avait un élément troublant c'est
que c'était lui qui avec sa propre
voiture a amené à la gare d'auxerre et à
partir de ce moment là elle part
normalement avec lui et elle n'arrive
pas à ce lieu de travail à wallon comme
prévu et on ne l'a jamais revu trois
semaines seulement avant son arrestation
lorsque nous l'avions interrogé sur le
cas jacqueline weiss emile louis
prétendait l'avoir seulement déposer à
la gare au japon super league la gare
ouais je dois voter dans le hall de la
gare c'est tout d'accord je suis parti
et on a pensé à une fugue vous avez
pensé quoi non annoncée des parents
n'étaient pas au fait de soucis qu au
bout d un mois qu'on importe c'est de
ces nouvelles c'est tout
tous ces meurtres
il les décrit comme quoi il a été envahi
par une bête il a eu un trou noir
pendant ce trou noir il est passé à
l'acte
et quand il se réveille elle était morte
c'est le seul la seule description qui
nous a donné des faits proprement dit on
a retrouvé des centaines de vêtements
donc plusieurs valises en carton comme
on avait à l'époque qui se sont
dégradées dans lesquelles les vêtements
étaient pillés ont trouvé du vernis du
maquillage ont conservé que c'était pour
des jeunes filles et tous ses vêtements
présentés à une particularité c'est que
toutes les étiquettes de ses vêtements
avaient été coupés et ça ce quelqu'un de
la dasu quelqu'un comme emile louis
pouvait y penser parce qu'en coupant les
étiquettes il enlevait un numéro ou non
en fait les enfants de la dass avait des
trousseaux il transcende et et un
trousseau divers etc trousseau été
marquée pour qu'on les distingue d'un
enfant à l'autre puisqu'ils avaient les
plus ou moins les mêmes vêtements et
donc toutes les étiquettes de ces
vêtements centaines de vêtements
d'objets plus d'une centaine en tous les
cas toutes les étiquettes et aient été
coupés donc on savait bien que toutes
ses vêtements étaient en lien entre
certains ses vêtements ont été reconnus
par des familles et ses vêtements
étaient bien sur cet emplacement
différent
emile louis et présenté au magistrat
il est écroué à la prison de draguignan
dans la tente de la réponse définitive
de la justice concernant la prescription
des crimes qu'il a maintenant avoué les
gendarmes connaissait l'existence d'un
document établi en 1993 mais qui restait
introuvable
et pour une fois au parquet d'auxerre on
s'active à la recherche de ce document
j'avais écrit sur un morceau de papier
blanc datés et signés mais je me
rappelais plus sur un coin de bureau du
procureur où je venais dénoncé des viols
dans l'association et ils ont retrouvé
ce papier j'avais écrit donc c'est un
acte interruptif puisque
le procureur a fait un envoi par fax de
demande auprès de la dass et on a pu
faire valider le fait qu'ils aient pro
prescription en janvier 2001 la cour de
cassation refuse définitivement la
prescription des faits emile louis se
rétracte le 16 janvier 2001 prétendant
être seulement le témoin d'un crime
commis par des inconnus mais coup dur
pour emile louis sa propre femme chantal
pas radier sa fille vont porter de
nouvelles accusations terribles qui vont
permettre son maintien en détention
ces deux femmes vont confiée aux
enquêteurs le fait les maltraitances ou
les actes qu'il a commis contre elle les
violences qu'il a commis contre elle
pour sa belle fille ce sont des actes de
viol sur mineur de moins de 15 ans pour
sa femme c'est des actes de torture des
actes de maltraitance de séquestration
etc et donc les enquêteurs vont prendre
ça
on prend ça en compte vont le déclarer
au parquet et des poursuites vont être
déclenchées sur cette base
emile louis ne s'en soucie guère il a
réponse à tout comment vous expliquez
que marilyn votre fille les eagles et po
paris à les malades c'est une
fabulatrice cette fois les mensonges de
passe plus emile louis et transféré à la
prison d'auxerre dans la tente de son
procès
les obsèques de jacqueline weiss et de
madeleine de juste donne lieu à une
cérémonie organisée par les familles de
disparus à la cathédrale d'auxerre
c'était tout ce qui est mouvant quoi
forcément forcément forcément que deux
cercueils
donc on avait mis des bougies qui
symbolisait les autres fassent et
c'était vraiment je vous rappel de 2 j
zay legras enfin c'était c'était voilà
quoi elle qui est très proches très
catholique et ses terrasses étaient
c'était l'horreur le rôle en horreur et
puis cette place quasiment 8 quoi le
prêtre qui a fait la cérémonie a subi
des pressions pour que l'enterrement
soit fait dans une autre église je
voulais quitter ce soit symbolique à la
cathédrale chaos - l'hommage qu'on
pouvait leur rendre donc on avait on va
dire privatiser tout la place parce que
je pensais que j'allais avoir beaucoup
d'officiels j'avais l'espoir
sauf que en officiel nous aurons il
uniquement la gendarmerie quelques
associations défendent handicapés ou
défense de victimes sur l'yonne
mais côté général das personnes même le
maire non absolument pas non ce jus
trouvé ça enfin le fassent jusqu'au bout
quoi je veux dire c'était pas il n'était
pas en cause ces gens là jusqu'au bout
je veux dire on a eu des
dysfonctionnements
même après la reconnaissance qu'il y ait
eu des victimes qui et milou et avoué
s'être enfin je veux dire c'est
hallucinant
pour corps at il fallu attendre 25 ans
pour que soit résolu une partie de la
sphère des disparus c'est ce que nous
allons essayer de comprendre
[Musique]
le dossier d' enquête préliminaire que
j'avais fait bon je l'avais déposée au
parquet comme toujours doit le faire
c'est normal et je demandais quelle
enquête officielle qui soit fait et à ma
grande surprise je n'ai jamais plus
entendu parler de ce dossier
une première question se pose
qu est il arrivé au rapport de synthèse
du gendarme jambert il a été remis le 23
juin 1984 au substitut du procureur de
l'époque daniel stilinovic
à l'époque jean vert en mer de tout le
monde personne ne veut l'écouter
personne n'avait le recevoir personne
est le seul en fait qu'ils acceptent de
l'écouter c'est moi parce que comme on
avait l'habitude de travailler ensemble
je demande au juge d'instruction vous
voulez vous instruire parce que j'ai
bien conscience que c'est maintenant que
le travail va démarrer c'est maintenant
d'un véritable les informations va
commencer le rapport de synthèse du
gendarme jambert et communiquer au juge
d'instruction le 26 juin 1984 il est
classée sans suite le même jour avec sur
le dossier
l'inscription non dans son rapport de
synthèse que voici
christian jambert donner les noms des
victimes et précisait le fait que tout
se trouvait dans l'environnement du
dénommé louis émile il concluait à la
responsabilité probable de ce dernier
dans l'est cette disparition et
demandait donc l'ouverture d'une enquête
juge d'instruction et et qui à cette
époque
monsieur bourguignon monsieur bourdin et
pourtant juge bourguignons avaient
toutes les raisons de s'intéresser à
emile louis qui avait avoué à christian
jambert en décembre 1980 avoir eu des
agissements de nature sexuelle sur des
filles handicapées confiant nourrissent
à sa concubine
madame binoche
annie est l'une d'entre elles emile
louis s'en souvient très bien mais c'est
madame binoche sa concubine qui
l'accusent de mauvais traitements
finalement c'est toute ma vie de bohème
elle aime chercher en voiture était
chauffeur de car c'est moi qui la prime
était à l'école qui préparait son petit
déjeuner est des insectes et des restes
en quarts et qu'est ce que tu as suivi
de laisser la terre qui m'a tapé argent
ou ensemble et à l'aider mais je suis
tout comme une verrue
mais j'ai engueulé mais qu'est-ce que
jamais paris jean victor avec elle tout
le temps tort mais va les voir le
calvaire que j'endure et l'emmener dans
des pièces epn à violer la justesse et
ben et la paix mais nous et puis la
meilleure présent de la lampe raison les
faits sont à la surprise de la partie
civile
requalifier en attentat à la pudeur
emile louis et condamné par la cour de
paris le 14 décembre 1983 à quatre ans
de prison ferme
une question se pose emile louis at il
bénéficié de soutiens à l'époque nicole
charrier la femme du directeur pierre
charrier a d'excellents rapports avec
émile ou non la mariée une femme qui m'a
jamais sa lumière au caire nicolas
charrier écrit même au juge
d'instruction une lettre de soutien à
emile louis il se voulait très près
compréhensif voire même éducateur
parfois un grand frère à qui on peut
tout dire
nicole charriait une personnalité
d'auxerre elle est même choisi par le
maire jean pierre soisson en 1989 pour
faire partie de l'équipe municipale sous
doute alors vous me disiez que vous êtes
vous étiez très très amis par exemple
enfin très amis que vous étiez en
relation par exemple avec monsieur jean
pierre soisson ben oui c'était notre
patron wen et vous faisiez la bringue
avec encore une fois bon une fois la
inaugurait aussi le les cars électriques
les premiers cas réalité il en perçoit
sans il ya le directeur départemental
des transports monsieur fauconnier qui
était derrière très lente et cgmp par
les friches à les voir rester
emile louis n'hésite pas à se vanter de
ses nombreuses relations
mais comment style en douter en sortant
de prison en 1984 il quitte rapidement
l'yonne
et il a changé de région il était habité
dans le midi et on y dit il est arrêté
encore deux fois pour les mêmes
problèmes de moeurs
encore une fois il avait fait des
attentats à la pudeur sur des enfants
particulièrement des garçonnets et il
avait arrêté encore pas les gens dans
l'île avec incarcéré à deux à deux
reprises différentes
[Musique]
la sphère en serait sans doute resté là
sans pierre monnoir et les familles de
disparus
[Musique]
il décide de porter plainte mais la
justice refuse de communiquer les
dossiers
aucun juge dit même aucun greffiers ne
les reçoit
on nous prend pour des clowns des
individus qui n'existe même pas je pense
qu'après tenu un chien que nous on nous
traite 1 elle avait même pas 16 ans
quand elle a disparu
personne n'a été prévenu message je ne
me serais jamais ils ont fiché
complètement des enfants il avait il
était responsable
il faut pas oublier que comme la dass à
l'époque avait la responsabilité d'un
enfant jusqu'à sa majorité et trois ans
après moi je vois mon mari qui pleurent
régulièrement je vois mes petites soeurs
de peine comme je dis comme l'a dit déjà
à une autre personne tout à l'heure ça
fait du bien se rencontrent et puis
aussi ça fait mal parce que mon humour
les mauvais choix
quand on voit quand ils ont voulu porter
plainte au départ on leur a dit mais
pour senna s'est retrouvée elle qu'est
ce que vous voulez qu'on en fasse la loi
est contre vous
je pense qu'il faut
il faut une justice avec un peu plus
d'humanité la justice d'accord mais avec
avec un peu de coeur c'est tout simple
je pensais c'est ce que les familles
demandent alors on sait bien que des
fois ça peut être lourd à gérer
psychologiquement c'est vrai il ya un
problème aussi dans la justice c'est à
dire lorsqu'un avion s'écrase
malheureusement il ya 300 personnes de
tuer donc la toux des psychologues
arrive eh bien nous il a fallu qu'on se
débrouille au départ par vos propres
moyens pour faire venir des psychologues
bénévoles
mais bon ils sont venus ponctuellement
pour leur demander de venir tous les
jours
comment le procureur casals expliquer le
fait qu'ils ne poursuivaient pas emile
louis ce que pour lui les prescriptions
il a dit d'ailleurs clairement s'est mis
lui rentré dans mon bureau et qu'il me
dise s'est moqué de ses filles à
prescription donc je serai obligé de
laisser partir
il n'y a même pas fait une enquête pour
savoir s'il y avait des actes
interruptif choc enfin pour des
professionnels choco la prescription en
matière de meurtres à l'époque n'était
que de 10 ans et le procureur casals
semblait persuadé d'avoir raison
en plus personne au palais de justice ne
retrouve le dossier jambert en février
1997 la justice auxerroises refuse
d'instruire cette affaire le procureur
s'opposent à l'ouverture d'une
information
plus tard il retrouvera la mémoire en
indiquant à son successeur que le
dossier jambert se trouve dans son
coffre le 7 mai 1997
la chambre d'accusation de paris or
donne enfin au juge d'instruire le
nouveau juge d'instruction monsieur
levandowski veut entendre le gendarme
jambert
j'attendais qu'il qui témoignent devant
devant le doyen des juges d'instruction
sur ce qu'il avait à dire et il s'est
suicidé avant de témoigner
j'ai un peu de mal à comprendre les
causes son suicide
son fils philippe lui aussi est
sceptique
il vous donnait pas du tout l'impression
de vouloir se suicider
non pas du tout
on aurait pu éventuellement les biens
souci d étant donné que bon il ya des
documents qui ont disparu dont il y
avait des documents donc sur les réseaux
pédophiles plus des documents donc sur
les disparues de l'yonne
quand j'ai appris que des documents
qu'il gardait chez lui relatif justement
sur son enquête sur louis avait disparu
là ça m'a quand même ça m'a quand même
un lapin peuvent interpeller
et puis quand j'ai quand on constate
aussi qu'il s'est suicidé peu de temps
avant d'être entendus comme témoins par
un magistrat instructeur chargé de
l'affairé louis on se dit ça fait deux
éléments qui chacun en soit ne veut rien
dire mais les deux les deux remis face à
face ça commence à prendre du sens la
mort de christian jambert reste pour
beaucoup un mystère même si le juge
d'instruction chargé de la faire a
décrété un non lieu son travail aura au
moins contribuer grandement à faire
passer me louis devant ses juges
[Musique]
plus de 25 ans après les faits l'
affaire des disparus est enfin porter
devant la justice le procès des 1000 wii
s'ouvre devant les assises de l'yonne le
9 novembre 2004 pour les familles de
victimes et pour leurs avocats
viviez ce banc il reste un espoir qu amy
louis parle enfin
nous avons encore une fois celui qui
détient la clé la khl et où se trouvent
ces corps nous souhaitons nous
souhaitons qu'ils parlent qu'ils disent
où se trouvent ces corps et milou et le
sait il ya déjà donné les indications
pour en retrouver deux nous souhaitons
que les derniers par respect pour les
familles pour qu'elles puissent faire
leur deuil les derniers core plus est
[Musique]
pour les familles une angoisse terrible
souffrance terrible de tout entendre
tout ce qui s'est passé comment
éventuellement il a pu les tuer etc
et puis je dirais pour moi un peu un
échec à un moment donné le président m'a
autorisé à s'adresser la parole
donc j'ai fait avec beaucoup de
compassion beaucoup d'empathie et cetera
en lui disant on va écouter vous faites
partie de nous puisque toutes ces
familles comme vous sont de la dass c
est
détenus sont les autres corps quoi dites
nous c'est important de savoir pour elle
pour sa durée je sais pas peut-être cinq
minutes mon intervention auprès de lui
et on était les yeux dans les yeux
il s'est levé pour prendre le micro et
j'ai senti ses épaules qui s'affaissait
donc qu'il était prête à parler quoi
voulez poser un peu tout ce qui vous est
tout ce qu'il avait en charge sur lui et
en le regardant je suis dit ça y est va
parler et je pense qu'il a vu dans mon
gars il s'est approché du micro il a
pris le micro c'est monsieur je suis pas
ses racines donc même à l'époque
l'avocat général a dit on n'est pas
passé loin mais bon c'est pas sa cote et
voilà c'était donc c'est un moment de
wade échec pour moi enfin des chasses
oui oui des chèques pour moi parce qu'on
aurait peut-être pu savoir
et voilà et puis ben la souffrance
contre les verdict est tombé
où toutes les familles à une monnaie
sûre il y avait toute la presse qui
étaient là effectivement toutes les
familles sont parties en pleurant dans
les buissons les coins de porte enfin
c'était difficilement gérable
[Musique]
il n'a rien avoué même si on a eu un
moment donné le sentiment quand le
président de la cour d'assises l'a
interrogé sur la bête qui avait en lui
puisqu'il a parlé à plusieurs fois de la
bête qui avait en lui qu' il n'était pas
très loin de dire que finalement il y
avait deux emile louis c'était me louis
respectueux des institutions upi s'était
mis lui
dans lequel la bête
finalement on pouvait ressortir on a
senti en lui une violence sourde qui
restait c'était des moments importants
et puis du procès est quand même
ressortis des images d'un personnage qui
n'avait jamais cessé de considérer que
les femmes étaient sa chose
à l'issue des débats la cour d'assises
de l'yonne condamné me louis à la
réclusion criminelle à perpétuité peine
qui sera confirmée par la cour d'appel
de paris en juin 2006
emile louis est mort en prison le 20
octobre 2013 en emportant avec lui ses
derniers secrets
[Musique]
l' affaire des disparus par est enfin
terminé mais coup de théâtre en 2018
elle rebondit avec cette fois un autre
prédateur
[Musique]
oh
le 16 février 2018 c'est la sphère marie
angèle domèce disparus 30 ans plus tôt à
l'âge de 19 ans qui refait surface
pour marie angèle la vie n'a jamais été
facile
dans son enfance c'est une petite fille
fragiles isolées en quête d'affection
c'est ce que nous explique son ancien
instituteur un à vingt son mariage elle
était une de mes élèves en classe
spécialisée dans les années 60 18 79 et
j'ai terminé ce de lui apprendre à lire
c'était une une enfant charmante très
attachante qui avait besoin de la
présence de l'adulte en permanence qui
avaient besoin d'être rassurés mariage
elle était une jeune fille naïve c'était
une jeune fille qui avaient été recensés
comme enfant intellectuellement
peut-être un peu un peu lente et donc
elle et elle croyait aussi beaucoup à ce
qu'elles entendent elles n'avaient pas
beaucoup de d'esprit critique sont des
enfants que l'on peut exploiter que l'on
peut tromper de manière assez simple
assez facile
le vendredi 8 juillet 1988 vers 15
heures
marie-angèle quitte le foyer de jeunes
filles leclerc four hall où elle réside
à auxerre avec en poche un billet de
train pour se rendre chez un membre de
sa famille à saint cyr les colons
son billet n'a jamais été utilisée
de toute manière personne ne la percevra
jamais à saint cyr les colons nous
avions rencontré son père en 2003 il
avait bien du mal à accepter la réaction
de la justice à l'époque quelconque
enquête gérer une enquête et ont pour
les cas ce qu'elle avait été bien menée
on ne régule mis en miroir et si on
l'aurait lui voir m'a fait vers l'est
qui connaissait bien marie angèle on le
relit voir naples et patricia on aurait
dû me voir moi qui suis le premier
concerné en tous les cas puisque son
père pas l'histoire
alors je connais rien de tout ça et au
bout d'un certain temps je ne sais pas
combien de temps au juste on a on
parlait justice on s'est amusé à apposer
un non lieu sur le dossier était
constitué je ne sais comment marie
angèle est majeur et la police comme la
justice ne croit pas à une disparition
inquiétante
et pourtant trente ans plus tard on
découvre enfin la cause de cette
disparition inexpliquée
michel fourniret condamné à perpétuité
pour cinq meurtres et deux assassinats
le 28 mai 2008 à vous du fond de sa
prison avoir enlevé et tué marie angèle
domèce
[Musique]
ces rebondissements n'aurait pas pu
avoir lieu sans le travail de la section
de recherches de dijon puisque ici
effectivement à dijon il ya une cellule
qui travaillent en permanence sur ces
affaires de meurtres non élucidés
la cellule cole cays c'est son nom
l'avocat de la section de recherches de
la gendarmerie de dijon s'était
intéressé au fait que michel fourniret
avait vécu avec son épouse monique
olivier là précisément où avait disparu
marie-angèle à saint cyr les colons ce
qui ressort de en tout cas du
comportement de michel fourniret c'est
que il le dit très clairement il joue
avec les enquêteurs si vous faites du
bon travail
si vous avez bien travaillé vérifier
tout si vous m'amenez la preuve que
c'est moi j'avoue si vous ne l'avez pas
fait si vous n'avez pas travaillé si
vous n'êtes pas sérieux
je vous dirai pour le père de marie
angèle
ce rebondissement est dur à accepter
pour les tramways j'avais mangé les
beaucoup de choses quoi un copain
tchèque un truc comme ça j'ai jamais cru
à a fondé ces formats je ne sais pas
trop si je pense y amant jean figeait de
de l'admettre qu'elle soit l'échelle et
peut-être charge cette angoisse qui
n'est au départ dans la disparition ne
s'arrête jamais quand ça dure trente ans
c'est juste une torture donc évidemment
que les parents voudraient retrouver le
corps de leur fille ou de leur soeur est
évidemment que les proches voudraient
lui donner une sépulture on a besoin de
ça pour pouvoir
à la suite de ses aveux
des fouilles sont organisées ici à saint
cyr les colons mais sans succès
on peut pas laisser ça comme si on ne
fait pas possible moi ce que je veux
c'est que chez kérastase marie angèle on
peut se les offrir
disons une tombe descend dans un super
pas comme ça dans la culture comment hk
on va recommencer à me battre comme on
s'est déjà battu autrefois je vais lui
que de toute façon j'ai 89 ans
est bon quand on a 80 le groupe s'attend
lamoureux en jour au lendemain mais j'ai
dû au temps j'aurai la force
je ferai ce qu'il faudrait faire je veux
que son lien pèse lui a payé c'est tout
vient pas l'histoire
il faut qu'ils payent même s'il est déjà
bouclé pour le restant de sa vie il faut
que ça ça lui soit mis à son crédit il
faut qu'il faut qu'ils finissent par
avouer c'est ça que je veux c'est qu'ils
finissent elles finissent par avouer
qu'elle vise exactement où il a déposé
la gauche voilà
à la demande des parties civiles des
fouilles supplémentaires doivent être
organisées pour tenter de retrouver le
corps de marie angèle mais les
informations données par fournirait 30
ans après reste très imprécises
[Musique]
aujourd'hui la sphère des disparus at
elle servi d'exemple en tout cas la
prescription a été porté à 20 ans en cas
de crime pour la nouvelle procureur
d'auxerre madama car moulin les leçons
ont été tirées
travail sur des protocoles pour toujours
s'améliorer d'un petit veau institutions
elles sont bien sûr une manne est donc
profondément imparfaite
je constate en tout cas dans l'yonne que
ces protocoles encore une fois qu'ils
sont nationaux qui sont déclinées suite
à des instructions du ministre de
l'intérieur et de la justice sont mis en
oeuvre avec avec une diligence toute
particulière dans l'yonne
les représentants des parties civiles
eux ne semblent pas partager ce discours
optimiste
j'ose espérer que dans des
établissements qui reçoivent des
personnes handicapées effectivement une
porte depuis une attention supérieur a
fait qu'elle ne revienne pas au qu'elle
ne rentre pas dans le centre où elles
sont accueillies par contre sur
l'organisation de l'enquète policière
sur l'organisation de la justice
malheureusement on est encore on vit
encore ce type de situation ou savez
nous sommes parties civiles pour des
familles dans le fer le landais la
sphère de la disparition de la petite
maelys d'humeur de la petite maï liste
et beaucoup de familles à la suite de
cette affaire sont venu s'adresser à la
justice en disant mes fils
mon amie a disparu sans qu'on n'ait plus
aucune trace dans la région est
malheureusement encore une fois on
s'aperçoit que ces enquêtes ne sont pas
coordonnées qu'on a affaire à des
services de des tribunaux différents que
les familles sont pas reçus qu'on les
laisse dans dans le silence réfik avant
moment où elles ont signalé ces
disparitions
on n'a rien fait nous a dit c'est trop
compliqué des disparitions d'adultes on
ne peut pas savoir
donc au fond on s'aperçoit encore que le
traitement aujourd'hui deux de ses
affaires de disparition n'est pas n'est
pas sérieusement pris en compte au
niveau judiciaire dans la sphère des
disparues de l'yonne
cinq corps de victimes n'ont toujours
pas été retrouvées et à auxerre il reste
une dizaine de femmes disparues dont on
est toujours sans nouvelle
[Musique]
et